más allá del cobi 19 el clima el consejo
de seguridad de la onu se reunió este
martes para discutir el impacto del
cambio climático en la paz y la
seguridad internacionales emergencia
climática es el tema más determinante de
nuestro tiempo el encuentro sirvió para
constatar el regreso de eeuu a los
compromisos por el clima tras la salida
de donald trump de la casa blanca
es hora de empezar a tratar la crisis
climática como una amenaza urgente a la
seguridad éste es literalmente el reto
de todas nuestras generaciones la
reunión fue presidida por el primer
ministro británico gordon song quien
estuvo acompañado por el naturalista
británico david attenborough
si continuamos por este camino
enfrentaremos el colapso de todo lo que
nos da seguridad
un elemento el de la seguridad que
también preocupa a emanuel macrón quien
dijo que de los 20 países más afectados
por los conflictos 12 se encuentran
entre los más vulnerables al impacto del
cambio climático el último curso como la
lucha contra el cambio climático y la
protección del medio
es claramente una cuestión de paz y
seguridad la discusión sobre el cambio
climático y seguridad van de la mano se
encontró con la oposición de china y
rúsia
estamos de acuerdo en que el cambio
climático puede exacerbar los conflictos
pero son los problemas ambientales la
verdadera causa ángel flip en noviembre
de glasgow en escocia acogerá la
conferencia climática de la onu cop 26
será la más importante desde los
acuerdos de parís en 2015 cuando cerca
de 200 países se comprometieron a
limitar el aumento de las temperaturas
muy por debajo de los 2 grados
centígrados
[Aplausos]